so my interest in privacy arose in
conversations with
helen nissenbaum a philosopher who
specializes in problems that arise in
the context of new technologies
so for the purposes of this talk we're
going to focus on
a database that's full of all kinds of
really useful but possibly sensitive
information
and we'll have a data analyst that
interacts with the database in a rather
formal fashion
she issues what we'll call queries and
gets answers
depending on the outcome of the first
query she can choose a second query
and get another answer and so on so it's
a completely adaptive setting
the census data was an original
motivating
scenario because census data privacy is
legally mandated
but there are lots of other applications
from epidemic detection
based on over-the-counter drug purchases
to analysis of loan application data for
evidence of discrimination and you can
come up with many many others
this is a really old problem with
literature that dates back
at least 50 years to warner's work on
randomized response which we'll discuss
later
so you might try to say
we haven't said what privacy is but
what we want is that if we have a data
set
that is sort of a good properly sampled
sample
from the general population that when we
ask questions of this data
we learn about the population as a whole
without compromising any of the privacy
of the individuals who are in the data
set
so you might think that
you can achieve this by restricting
attention to
just statistical queries now i haven't
said what statistical queries are either
but you probably have some kind of
intuition
right your intuition is that the
statistic is in fact
giving you some understanding of the
underlying population
that's why statisticians do their stuff
and you also have the intuition
that the data of any one individual
shouldn't really affect the outcome of
the statistical analysis too much
again that's why statistics is supposed
to work it's not supposed to be about
any single individual
it's supposed to talk to you about the
population as a whole
so suppose we were able to formalize
this and say okay the
um the analyst can just ask statistical
queries
so your intuition but just in the legal
right so um i call this the statistics
masquerade
and you know intuition is just
completely wrong here so here are a few
examples
the first is the differencing attack so
suppose we ask how many members of the
house of representatives have the sickle
cell trait
so your intuition is that if you get the
answer to that question
you really don't know anything about the
status of any
individual in the house of
representatives
just an intuition but suppose we also
give you the answer
to a second question exact answer to a
second question which is
how many members of the house of
representatives other than the speaker
of the house
have the sickle cell trait so if you
have the exact answers to both of these
questions you can of course determine
the sickle cell status of the speaker so
it's not private at all
there are also other kinds of attacks a
sort of needle in a haystack attack
that um allows
the possibility of determining the
presence of an individual's genomic data
in a geno in a genome-wide association
study case group
based only on aggregate statistics about
the proteins
in the in the dna of the various people
in the case group
and there are this big bang attacks also
known as dunornism attacks
which show that given statistics for
multiple overlapping large subsets of
the population
you can actually reconstruct sensitive
attributes
for everybody in the in the population
so these lead to a sort of fundamental
law of information recovery
which says that overly accurate answers
for too many statistics or estimates of
too many statistics
is blatantly non-private and there are
many instantiations of this particular
fundamental law
we won't have a chance to go into them
now
but it's a lot worse than that and it's
worse than that
because
statistics that are produced or actions
that are taken
based on analysis of data and that are
observable in public
take place in a network world where
information flows and combines in
mysterious ways and every one of these
pictures
indicates a real story either from the
literature or from actual real life uh
attack
so we're not doing things in vitro
things are happening in vivo and it's a
really wild wild west out there
so latanya sweeney when she was
cto of the federal trade commission
uh advocating in fact for differential
privacy put it this way computer science
got us into this mess
can computer science get us out of it
so you guys are cryptographers
and you know that among and enabling the
tremendous advances of modern
cryptography
is a focus on definitions so we're going
to try to define now what we want to
mean by privacy
what do we mean by privacy preserving
data analysis
so here we have this database and helen
is in the database what kind of privacy
or protection
is it that we would like to offer to
helen
so the first thing that you might try is
that we shouldn't be able to learn
anything
new about helen that is the analyst
might know a lot about helen to begin
with that's called auxiliary information
but by interacting with the database the
analysts shouldn't learn anything new
that she didn't already know
and not only is this
sort of the analog of semantic security
for a cryptosystem
but it was also proposed five years
before the definition of semantic
security
by the statistician tordellinius for
what he envisioned for statistical
database
the problem with this definition is that
if we satisfy it then what is the point
of our statistical database
so to illustrate this suppose i'm from
mars
and i incorrectly believe that all
humans have two left feet
so in particular i believe that helen
has two left feet
and i interact with the data set and i
learn
that the vast majority of people have
one left foot
and one right foot so now
my beliefs about helen have changed
and the question is has her
privacy been compromised
and this is a judgment call
we chose to say no to say that this is
not a privacy compromise
and the justification for this is that
the same thing would have happened if
helen had been replaced in the data set
by another random member of the
population
in which case we're sort of
justified in a view that the database
isn't leaking something specifically
about helen
but rather about the population as a
whole
this is also known as stability
and we will come back to that
but learning the same things when you
perturb the data set slightly
is a very useful property to have
so this brings us to the english
language definition of differential
privacy
which says that the outcome of any
statistical analysis
is essentially equally likely
independent of whether any individual
joins or refrains from joining the data
set
so we'll learn the same things with this
with very similar probabilities
if helen goes away latonya joins helen's
replaced by latonya
and other small perturbations in the
data set
clearly if we completely change the data
set
we may get totally different answers
like if we replace all the men by women
we'll get some very different answers
and that's to be expected that's what we
want that's utility
but small changes shouldn't change
things very much
now as you'll see
differential privacy is an extremely
strong
definition of privacy it's very very
demanding
and so let me give you a little bit of
intuition
as to why we could still do something
useful
and actually get some meaningful data
analysis
even if we maintain this strong
definition and the key to that
is that stability is known to
yield generalizability and in fact be
required for generalizability
you want that the things you learn from
the data set
you should be able should apply to the
population as a whole
and they shouldn't just be over fit to
your data
that that's called generalizability
and that's um strongly connected to
stability
yes what's your question how do you
define a small change don't worry
it'll come
so the key point here is that privacy
and generalizability are aligned and
while you'll often hear about attention
between
privacy and utility here's a sense in
which privacy and utility
learning about the population as a whole
are in fact aligned and they are not in
tension
so here's the formal definition of
differential privacy
and this answers your question
first i have to tell you what
is a pair of adjacent data sets
so we say that a pair of data sets x and
y are adjacent
if one of them is contained in the other
and the larger one contains the data of
just one more person
so the whole data set versus the whole
data set minus helen
the whole data set versus the hold data
set plus a new member
latonya those are adjacent data sets
so our algorithms are going to be
randomized they're going to take a data
set as an input and they're going to
chomp on it
and they're going to have some random
bits and so when the data set
is x m of x will
be a probability distribution on outputs
and similarly for m of y
finally an event is just a subset
of the range of the mechanism the
algorithm for some reason the algorithms
are always called mechanisms
so now we have everything we need to
give the definition
we say that a mechanism or algorithm m
gives epsilon differential privacy
if for every pair every pair
of adjacent data sets x and y
and every event x the probability s the
probability that we observe
s when the database is x is close to
within an e to the epsilon factor times
the probability
that we observe this event when the data
set is y
and notice that in the definition the
role of x and y are completely symmetric
so we can flip them
and so we would have the probability of
m of y is in
s is at most e the epsilon times the
probability of m of x's and s as well
and the probability space is over the
randomness
of the algorithm not over
the choice of the data set
so it's a worst case guarantee because
it's guaranteed for every pair of data
sets
it has absolutely nothing to do with who
happens to know what
this is just a statement about the
behavior of an algorithm
it doesn't care what somebody
interacting with the algorithm or
calling the algorithm happens to know or
not know
and since this is the randomness
of the algorithm and the algorithm
we're always going to assume is run by a
trusted and trustworthy
curator the randomness is in the hands
of the good guys we control it
so that's very important
and informally for now i'm going to
describe
i'm going to call epsilon the privacy
loss
okay now there are a few properties yes
so how do how does this definition
compare to
saying that statistical distance between
hamifax and mfy
is small there is a relationship it's
close
um yeah
you had the english ex yes
did that formation exist before uh no
that formulation did not exist people
could have
thought about before right
no one formulated it that way no
that's correct so it's new
so let me describe some properties that
flow
from the definition not from any
particular implementation
first of all if an algorithm is
differentially private
it's differentially private no matter
what anybody happens to know i made this
point earlier
so in fact it's immune not only to all
auxiliary information
right now but it's immune to any
auxiliary information
that the adversary might learn three
years from now
thinking back over all of science that
has
evolved in the last three years and the
answers that were received today
if an algorithm is epsilon
differentially private then it is
automatically
k epsilon differentially private for a
set of size k
so smaller epsilon is better privacy
k epsilon is bigger than epsilon but
nonetheless
there is some natural group privacy
we can understand and analyze
the cumulative privacy loss over
multiple analyses
and varying
very rigorously in the worst case the
epsilons add up
i will later i prefer to wait
from composition we get
the most important property which is
programmability so what it says is
if you understand a few simple
differentially private primitives you
can now
combine these primitives in interesting
and creative ways
to find privacy preserving methods
for more complicated
analytical tasks
so we're in a situation that's a lot
like you have with algorithms in general
we know how to add and we know how to
multiply
and all of algorithms is the question of
combining these abilities of adding and
multiplying
in creative and interesting ways in
order to optimize various
kinds of um costs such as time
and number of random bits and space and
things like that
so in differential privacy we want to do
those same sort of things
but we want also to minimize one more
thing and that is cumulative privacy
loss
so this is where all of the power of
differential privacy comes from
and there's nothing else that has this
kind of power
for private data analysis
so let's look at a couple of ways of
achieving differential privacy
some of those simple computational
building blocks
so here's something that's none of my
business
and you probably have heard of this
approach
this is due to warner in 1965. so i'm
going to ask this question
but of course you're not going to tell
me the answer directly
what you're going to do is flip a coin
and if it's heads
you're going to answer randomly that is
you'll flip a second coin
and respond yes of heads and no
otherwise and if it's tails you're going
to answer me honestly
so this is
with a slight change to the definition
this is differentially private
and you can analyze in a really easy way
what is the parameter epsilon that you
get
so it's not hard to see that the
probability that you say yes
given that the truth is yes divided by
the probability that you say
yes given that the truth is no is a
third
and similarly for answers of m
of no so um
what that tells us is that this log
ratio
is um is uh the natural log of 3
which is 1.098 roughly
so statisticians are very familiar with
that
and you if you're interested in the
question of how many people in the data
set xyz last night
you can estimate that by because you
understand the random noise and you can
sort of factor that out
and what you'll end up with is an
absolute error that's tightly
concentrated around square root of n
so things cancel out nicely and
you'll be able to right fine and
sometimes we talk about fractional error
so we're asking not how many people in
the data set but what fraction of the
people in the data set
and so the fractional one will be an
answer between zero and one
and fractional error here looks like one
over root n
here's a second general approach
oh i should mention that randomized
response
is actually being deployed by google
to estimate the prevalence of malware
in the chrome browser and they're using
the
properties of differential privacy to
analyze cumulative privacy loss
okay so suppose we want to look at
getting estimates of real valued
functions
so here's a data set and we're
interested in
some function f of the data set x and
this star
is f of x now
remember that we need to
sort of blur the difference between when
the data set is x
and when the data set is any neighboring
y so here's a neighboring data set y
it has one more point in it and f of y
is now this yellow star instead of the
red star
so we want to add some noise that will
obscure the difference between f of x
and f of y
so maybe we'll have this be the
probability distribution on outputs when
the data set is x
and this will be the probability
distribution on outputs when the data
set is y
and what we need is that at all points
here these two guys
uh satisfy that ratio of e to the
epsilon
that the ratio is always between e to
the minus epsilon and e to the plus
epsilon
what this suggests is that um
sorry all right so let's let
delta f which is called the sensitivity
of the function f
denote the maximum over all pairs of
adjacent data sets x and y
of the absolute value of f of x minus f
of y so this is
how much what magnitude
the noise has to cover or has to obscure
so informally the theorem statement is
going to be that to achieve
epsilon differential privacy it suffices
to add symmetric noise
that is scaled to this quantity
so let's talk about this quantity for a
minute by scale two things sort of
standard deviation roughly that's how
big you expect it to be
first of all the noise depends on the
function
f and on epsilon but not
in any way on the data set nor on the
size of the data set
so if we have a function
that is sort of monotonically growing in
the size of the data set
things like counting queries how many
people in the data set are over six feet
tall
for example this is something that's
growing within
but the noise distribution is fixed and
independent of n
so when n gets large enough the noise is
completely tiny compared to the answer
so we can
now something about this form if my
presence or absence
can radically change the value of the
function
we're going to have to add more noise
bigger noise to hide
my presence or absence so here's delta f
in the numerator where it belongs now a
smaller epsilon
is better privacy and
if you want a lot of privacy then you
kind of have to
broaden the the distribution make it a
wide standard deviation and if you don't
care so much about privacy
it can be smaller so here's epsilon in
the denominator
where it belongs when epsilon is small
this blows up
so everything has the right form
moreover because of the fact
that the noise sort of stays fixed but
the size of the database and therefore
the value of f
could grow we tend to think about this
as privacy in the land of plenty
when data are plentiful this gives good
answers
if the data set is very tiny
the true answer will be completely
obscured by noise
that's just true so differential privacy
is
not a tool to use on tiny data sets
so here's the exact distribution that we
like it's the laplace distribution
so the parameter is b and
this is the density function
so the density function is dropping off
exponentially
in z divided by the parameter
and the standard deviation is roughly
the parameter so
increasing the parameter will flatten
the curve
give you better privacy
the same argument actually will work
and i'll give you the argument in a
minute for vector-valued functions so
there was nothing really really special
about um the fact that i was looking at
real valued function
here we just have to redefine
sensitivity to instead of being
just an absolute value here it's a one
norm
which is the sum of the absolute values
in each of the coordinates
so what you would do is
you compute the sensitivity and you add
noise scale to the sensitivity over
epsilon independently drawn for every
coordinate of the output
and the same thing will also work if we
want the answers to many functions
we can just think of the many functions
as giving us a vector
and we can look at the sensitivity of
this string of functions
okay so why does it work um
so we'll use shorthand here
to uh for the for the density function
of m of x at t
so we're interested for two adjacent
data sets
in this ratio and
um plugging in what we had
for the density function
we have t minus f of x
divided by the parameter in the
numerator
and t minus f of y divided by the
parameter
in the exponent in the denominator so
when you put those together
and we apply the triangle inequality we
get here something that's at most the
one norm of f of x minus f of y
which of course is bounded by delta f by
definition
and the delta f's cancel and we get
exponential and epsilon
so here's the first application
that uh i know of that that really told
me
something was happening adam smith told
me this uh
application and it really got my
attention
so histogram query
a lot of
statistics are uh have the following
form
you have your space of people your
universe of possible people
you carve the universe up into disjoint
chunks for example people with annual
income between zero
and twenty five thousand people with
annual income
between a little more than twenty five
thousand and fifty thousand
a little more than fifty and seventy
five those are disjoint chunks
of the of the universe of what
people's annual income could be and you
want to know for each chunk
how many people are in that chunk
the standard histogram query
so you could view this as
a large collection of counting queries
one for each chunk and you could say
okay this is a high dimensional query
but if you think about a histogram
if you add or delete one person
you will only change the count in one
cell
and you'll only change that count by at
most one
and so the sensitivity of the query is
just one
and so it's enough to add noise that's
scaled to one over epsilon
in each of these different cells and
release the result
sorry maybe it doesn't matter but
wouldn't you be changing the count in
two cells
no because we're just adding a person
and that person can only live in one
possible cell
another is now earning 30 000 i defined
adjacent data sets
as one is a subset of the other and the
data has the data of just one more
person
you're absolutely right and sometimes
it's very helpful to think of
adjacency as what happens if you move
somebody around and then you get the
factor of two
well we also want to do some kind of a
of an accuracy analysis i've told you
about privacy but what about accuracy
so this is the kind of result that we
can get and i'll show you how in a
second
uh suppose you want to know which from a
set of 10 000 first names were the most
popular in the 2010 census
okay so this is a histogram query with
10 000 cells
so if we take epsilon to be one then we
can argue that with probability 0.05
at 9 5 no estimate will er by more than
about 12.
so for this we have to
introduce a notion of alpha beta
accuracy
which is the following a mechanism
is alpha beta accurate with respect to a
set of queries q
if for all databases x with probability
at least one minus beta
the output m of x permits the analyst to
compute an
approximation that's within alpha
of truth for every query
okay so
whenever i talk about alpha beta
accuracy i'm always talking about with
respect to all of the queries
in the set simultaneously
all right so we're asking what accuracy
does the laplace mechanism
provide for k counting queries counting
queries are going to be our running
example
so with k queries we're going to have
all the
the sensitivity the l1 the sensitivity
for k queries
k counting queries is in general k
because adding one person
might say increase the counts for all of
the k queries
and so the l1 norm of the difference of
the counts on
f of x and on f y will be k
so we're going to add noise um that's
drawn from parameter k
over epsilon and we're going to use this
fact about
the laplace distribution that the
probability that we exceed
t times the parameter is at most e to
the minus t
so we're going to
definition is just yes that m is a pack
and this is how good of a pack it is is
that
fair to say i guess it's an additive air
it's an additive error
okay so we're just going to ah i'm just
going to look at the probability
uh of exceeding our parameter by a
factor of t
and we're going to apply a union bound
and our fact
so we get that k over beta would be e to
the t
so t is long k over beta and we get that
alpha is k over epsilon
times the log of k over beta
okay so for the laplace mechanism
this is our privacy guarantee accuracy
guarantee
so let's look at the case where k is one
just a single counting query in
randomized response
we had an error of root n here
we're going to have an error of one over
epsilon
so it's better epsilon is typically a we
think of epsilon as a small constant
and um we get something that's at least
potentially sensible as long as we don't
ask
n queries we get some non-trivial
accuracy for
almost up to n queries
now here's another trick
another little toy suppose
we have a bunch of functions and we want
to know
which function achieves the maximum
value on this set
so for example g1 of x might be how many
people like ping pong
g2 of x might be how many people like to
eat muffin tops g3 of x
can be how many people in the data set
go running regularly and so on
so one person can can affect many
different of these things
but you might want to know simply what
is the most popular hobby of these
hobbies
so
in general for general functions
so okay so one thing that you could do
of course is add noise
that is scaled to the sensitivity of the
vector that you would get
g1 g2 and so on and so forth but
obviously that's not what we want to do
and what we are going to do is we're
going to add noise that's scaled
to the maximum sensitivity of any single
one of these
but do not release the outcome do this
computation
still inside the curator and report
only the index of the function that has
the largest
noisy max hence the name report noisy
arg max
that will tell you which of these things
is
well certainly tell you which is the
largest noisy value and if there's a gap
between
the true largest value and the second
largest value
you're very likely to get the truly
largest value
if the first and second and you can
extend that of course
are fairly close then who knows what
you'll get as an outcome
the key point is you don't reveal any
noisy values
except anyways values at all and the
proof of differential privacy is by
straightforward case analysis
so this is an example of a minimization
principle
we compute much more than we actually
release
and by doing so we're able to get by
with less distortion
here's a tremendously powerful
generalization of report noisy arg max
oh and of course what i said also
applies to argmin
all right this is going to apply to very
general notions of utility
so we've been talking about l1 error
when we were
just adding noise to real valued
functions but we might look at l2
error or maybe we have a differentially
out private algorithm that's producing
some kind of a classifier
and our notion of utility
is small smallness of classification
error
so minus classification error
and in general we want to use this when
adding noise makes
no sense so one way in which adding
noise makes no sense is if you say
which is the most popular hobby it
doesn't make sense to add noise to the
answer table tennis
just not meaningful um
and in particular it might be the case
that what you're computing is a price
for an auction
and if you add noise in particular if
you add positive noise to it
you might suddenly price yourself out of
having any buyers at all
so the general goal will be to maximize
some arbitrary utility function
sorry
this should not be y this should be the
value uh psi
which is what it'll look like just about
everywhere else
so we have
and that should be a capital xi so we
we're looking at functions whose outputs
are some
objects they could be strings they could
be experts they could be small databases
they could be prices
and each of these things has a utility
for x which we denote
utility of psi on x
and the intuition here
is that we will output the element
psi with the probability that it's
proportional to e to something
so what do we have in the exponent we
have the utility
how good is psi as an answer for x
times epsilon divided by delta u so this
epsilon over delta u should have a
familiar field to you you've seen this
before
so the inverse of delta f over epsilon
and the intuition for why this works is
the following
let's look at two neighboring databases
x and y
so we're when the database is x we'll
output
psi with probability that looks like e
to the utility of x
psi for x to this power
and when the database is y we'll output
psi
with this probability to the same power
delta u is the sensitivity of the
utility function
it says how much does the utility change
if i change the database by one element
so delta u is
bounds this difference
and so this guy is bounded by delta u
and this is delta u and they cancel and
we get epsilon
and formally this mechanism called the
exponential mechanism
due to mcsharian talwar does just what i
told you although
there's a normalization factor and
because of that we get an extra factor
of two up here in the exponent
now similar to the proof of alpha beta
accuracy we want to prove something
about how good is the
exponential mechanism and
by the way a little bit of thought will
show you that the laplace mechanism
is the exponential mechanism on reels
so we're going to have a very similar
looking proof
so if this is the set of possible
outputs
and psi star is the set of optimal
utility outputs
those whose utility is
no worse than any other
then my claim is that for all
values v the probability that the
utility
on what is produced here when the
database is x
is bounded by v
is at most this quantity so what is this
quantity
in the numerator we see that if the
utility of psi
is bounded by v then the unnormalized
weight of
psi is at most this by definition of the
mechanism
and there are most sci many elements of
that form
and then
if
psi star is the set of optimal elements
they have unnormalized weight e to the u
star
by definition so their total
unnormalized weight sorry is e to the
epsilon u star over two delta u
so the normalization term here is at
least
psi star times e to the u star over 2
delta u
and then you just do the arithmetic and
the exponents and we get v minus u star
so the probability that we have utility
at most v
is bounded by this over that
okay so i'm going to make a historical
note about this
um perhaps the motivating scenario
for mixurian talwar was
unlimited supply auctions so in these
auctions
bidders have demand curves that describe
for every possible price in a fixed
interval the number of goods that they
want to purchase if the price is p
and let's say that each of them has a
total budget of one
so
the auctioneer can choose a price
that will optimize revenue so the price
uh
the revenue would be p times the sum
over
how much he's getting from each of the
different bidders
and mccherry and tulwar's idea was that
you should use select the price using
the exponential mechanism
where you define the utility of a price
to simply be the revenue
and if you do this you get an auction
that's approximately truthful in the
sense that an individual
can't substantially change the outcome
by changing her bid
why
because the exponential mechanism is
differentially private
so you expect roughly the same answers
no matter how somebody changes her bid
as a byproduct they also got
collusion resistance that is to say
remember that if something is epsilon
differentially private it's
k epsilon differentially private for a
group of size k
so if you have a small number of
colluding bidders
they can't have much of an impact on the
price that's chosen or the distribution
on prices that are chosen
and to my knowledge this is the first
instance of differential privacy
providing a new result
on a problem that has nothing to do with
privacy in other words collusion
resistant
uh auctions of this type of general the
connection between
like
so the idea the idea of approximate
truthfulness
uh or differential privacy as a solution
concept has in fact been very fruitful
yes and there are several
works that develop that and also the
connection in general to economics
here is an absolutely radical
application of the exponential mechanism
which totally changed my understanding
of uh
of what we could possibly hope for in
differential privacy
so this is going to be a mechanism that
will answer
hugely many counting queries
so we're given an nro database and a
collection
queue of counting queries i'm sorry i
yeah and the goal is going to be
to produce a synthetic database
sai that gives a good approximation to
the answers to the questions what
fraction of the rows of the original
database satisfy property p
for every property p in our set
so what do i mean by a synthetic data
base
so i'm assuming that the database
is a collection of rows where each row
is drawn from a universe of elements
a synthetic database also has
rows that are drawn from a from the same
universe of elements
those rows might or might not intersect
with the original database
but what's desired is that the answers
to the counting queries should be
approximately the same the fractional
counting queries should be approximately
the same
so our output space for the exponential
mechanism
is going to be the set of all small
databases i'll tell you what small is in
a moment
we need a utility function the utility
of a small database
psi for x is the maximum
fractional difference of q of x versus q
of psi
so it's telling you what's the worst
case error for among
the queries in that set queue for this
thing
and the sensitivity of this utility
function
is just one over n if i have an n
element database and i take something
out
i'm going to change the utility by at
most one over n these are fractional
counting queries not whole counting
queries
so the exponential mechanism it says
assign a weight to each database each
little database psi proportional to
e to the epsilon over
the sensitivity i'm sorry e to its
utility
times epsilon over the sensitivity
now to analyze this amazing object
we need the notion of an alphanet with
respect to the set of queries q
so we're looking at small databases
whatever small means
and the claim is that every database
so an alphanet is a set of small
databases that has the property that
every arbitrary size
database is alpha close on these
fractional queries
to some element in the net with respect
to this
case so it says that the maximum over
all q
of q of x minus q of psi is bounded by
alpha
this is true for every database x
independent of size
that's an alphanet and the wonderful
fact
is that for fractional counting queries
there is an alphanet
of this size this is the set of
universe the set of database for those
possible database rows
and this is the log of the number of
queries divided by alpha squared
this is for an alpha net so that says
that the set of all small databases
where small means
this size forms an i'm sorry
forms an alphanet
so this is the set this alphanet is the
set to which we're going to apply the
exponential mechanism
when we do it we take this theorem that
we proved here
and we take a corollary where what i've
done is i've plugged in this horrible
looking thing
for the value v and chugged through the
arithmetic
and we used that together with the bound
on the size of the alphanet
the size of the alphanet would be this
item up here
to conclude two alpha beta accuracy for
this ugly looking thing
what is the ugly looking thing it
basically says that
the absolute error is going to be n to
the two thirds at most
n to the two thirds times this quantity
so logarithmic in the number of queries
logarithmic in the number of queries so
if the
universe is pretty small we can ask an
exponentially
large number of queries not two to the n
but still
exponentially large that's amazing
and um
but it also tells us
if we think of the data set as being
sort of each data element is a
d bit long
vector you know so you've got d
attributes
and it this gives us some
limits on what we can hope for with this
particular technique
if this thing to the one-third is as
large as
n to the one-third then we would get an
absolute error that was worse than n and
things wouldn't be interesting anymore
so it says that our we can handle tons
of queries on
relatively low dimensional data but
the data matrix has to be relatively
thin it can't it can't be square
for example
so there is dimensionality unfortunately
plays
a constraining role for us
what about efficiency
generating synthetic data can be hard
so here's an example that comes from
some joint work in 2009
we have a distribution we're going to
need a distribution on databases
and because you know when you talk about
computational hardness you need
distributions and families and
blah blah blah blah blah the general
form looks like this
our distribution is parameterized by the
security parameter
and we're going to rely on digital
signatures
so here's how we're going to here's
going to be how how the databases are
generated
first we choose a single sign verify key
pair from our digital signature scheme
and we're going to create a database
where each row
is just the message that we're signing
for a random message the signature and
we're going to throw the verification
key in there for good measure so this is
what a row looks like in the database
now we're going to have one query for
each verification key
so the query is going to be what
fraction of the rows in the databases
are valid signatures
under vk now
consider and a curator who has a whole
bunch of
data rows that look like this but does
not know the signing key
and the job of that curator is to come
up with synthetic data
so our curator is in trouble she can
choose subsets of rows in the original
data set
but she can never come up with
a row that isn't in the original data
set because she can't forge the
signature
so an efficient curator cannot generate
a synthetic database that yields
approximately correct answers for vk
stars with
for this key without leaking rows that
are in the original database
so cryptography plays a role here of
telling us about hardness
now here's an almost correct intuition
though suppose we say okay
curator you don't have to release a
synthetic database
but
release a synopsis that has the same
functionality
now i'm lying here a little bit but the
almost correct intuition is that that's
pretty trivial
you would just publish the key vk star
it's a little problematic but it's not
crazy so i just want
to place that out there for you to see
that
uh the synopsis could be easier than
creating synthetic data
so how much easier well what do we want
from a synopsis
we want to maintain the functionality of
the database with respect to our set of
queries
so that means that we still want to hide
the presence or absence of any
individual
but we're going to have now basically
the opposite of trader tracing
and what we're going to be able to show
is that trader tracing implies there are
hard to sanitize distributions
and we can show the converse
now um does anybody here not know what
trader tracing is
okay so very briefly um
the trader tracing scheme consists of
various little
subroutines where the main idea
is that you want to hand special
decryption keys
one key to each of your paying users
you want to be able to broadcast
encrypted content
so that your um
your legitimate users can decrypt and
purcha and get this content
but you want to prevent
any subset of the users from reselling
the content
so we imagine that the way they resell
the content
is they get together and they create
what we call a pirate decoder they take
the keys that they have and they do
something or other
and they get a pirate decoder which they
then sell to other people
and the pirate decoder has the
functionality
of decoding bad for the system
but here's where the trader tracing
comes in
there's a tracing algorithm and the
tracer can ask
the pirate decoder to decode a couple of
ciphertexts
and gets back the answer and based on
that
the tracer can accuse
correctly at least one person
one of the colluders that's the general
shape of a trader tracing scheme
so some user in the coalition will be
traced to end users who are
not in the coalition who did not collude
and who didn't do anything wrong will
never be accused
so for us we're going to start with the
trader tracing scheme
some private key length and some
ciphertext lengths we're going to have
one universe element these are our
database rows for each private key
so this is the key that we gave to user
one this is the key that we give to user
two and so on
and the query set is going to be
what fraction of rows uh
for what fraction of rows i is it the
case that when we apply the decryption
key
for user i here to the ciphertext c we
get one
so if
we had a synopsis something that
captured
the functionality of this data set even
though it isn't a synthetic data set
uh what would it mean to capture the
functionality well
the fraction is going to be either 0 or
1
so the decryption in other words will
it'll just be the decryption of c
and tracing will reveal at least one of
the keys and it never falsely accuses
and so this would violate differential
privacy
because we'd have an answer that can
show up when a certain key is in the
data set
with non-zero probability and have
probability of 0
when the user is not in the data set
now no one ever talks about this so
we're going to have one slide on the
intuition for the converse
if we start with a hard to sanitize
distribution on databases and no
i haven't define it but i'm just telling
you that it means in some
strong sense it's going to be difficult
to come up with a synopsis that has the
right functionality and preserves
privacy
so we're going to choose a random
database from this distribution
we're going to have a bunch of counting
queries and every user key
is just going to be a small subset of
the rows of the
actual data set this is a user key
so we know and this was at the heart of
the small db
alphanet argument that almost every
small subset of the rows will give you
approximately the right functionality
and so we'll use those fractional counts
to encrypt bits
and the hardness of sanitization when we
actually get around to defining it
will will will tell us that it's
possible to identify a participant
in a coalition-built set-top box that'll
end up happening by definition
so just the most recent results i think
on this are some attractive results
the following assuming secure
cryptography exists differentially
private algorithms
for the following will require
exponential time
first of all synthetic data for two-way
marginals
and this is a much much more intuitive
natural set of queries than
our weird contrived things that involve
signatures and the proof
uh uses digital signatures and pcps
and if you could do differentially
private synopsis release that will
handle n-squared arbitrary counting
queries i mean that also is hard
and that's a result of omen and again
the proof uses
trader tracing schemes
and here's where i'd like to break
like
i don't think that the two-way marginals
is at all pathologically so
i'm
this is very general these are very
general two-way marginal queries
it's very tricky to define privacy to
only hold for some forms of data and not
others
is the problem so that's a very
problematic relaxation yeah
so think about it okay here's where i'd
like to break
you